et sat down with Bachelor star Corinne
elympios to celebrate her new team corn
clothing line she's been busy and has
not been watching Dancing with the Stars
but we got her reaction to X Nick vials
most memorable year number which was
inspired by his season of The Bachelor
what is your reaction to this dance I'm
very happy for them
sorry that was like really I was just
watching when I said I was like I gotta
be honest your voice with a little
deadpan no I am very happy for them if
they're happy hey why not do you think
that they're happy you know what I don't
I have mixed emotions about it I mean I
really hope for the both of them they
are but sometimes it looks like they're
not to be perfectly honest I mean it
just really looks like they're not and
it really looks like sometimes they're
doing things to get attention I just
feel like in the public eye she's not
that real like she wasn't women tell all
and it's a little bit more forced Nick
always had my back from the beginning
and I really appreciate that and he
really is a really kind amazing guy and
vanessa is very lucky to have won his
heart if it's you know real but um
sometimes it does look a little phony to
me
[Music]
you